it's great to welcome to the program
today crystal ball who's a journalist
pundit co-host of the hills rising and
also author of the book the populist
guide to 2020 a new right and new left
are rising great to have you on crystal
thank you so much for having me David I
really appreciate it
so to start with we hear from Steve
Bannon all about Donald Trump's populism
and of course that version of populism
is very different than what we see
espoused by people like Bernie Sanders
it's very different from what we saw in
Tahrir Square Occupy Wall Street and so
on and so forth how would you kind of
characterize the main differences
between right populism and left populism
it's such a good question such an
important question and one that we do
try to grapple with some in the book and
I mean as you're just to give a little
bit of context here and your viewers
probably know some of this but on our
show rising I'm the left populist host
and my co-host sagar is the right
populist toast and we have many
disagreements and the kanto politics
should be prosecuted here and around the
world but what we try to do in the book
is explore the idea of what politics
could look like in the future if instead
of having the situation that I believe
we have now where both political parties
essentially fight for the needs of the
rich and that comes with a certain
bipartisan consensus you know I think
it's a myth that there's just gridlock
in Washington in fact there's quite a
lot of consensus around the war machine
there's been a lot of consensus around
trade deals there's been a lot of
consensus around cutting taxes for
corporations and creating loopholes that
allow corporations to get away with
paying less in taxes we just saw you
know a day after impeachment Democrats
partner with Trump to pass his new trade
deal right so there has been a lot of
bipartisan consensus where would be the
overlap and where would be the
difference if you had you know a Steve
Bannon sort of right-wing party and a
Bernie Sanders left-wing party that were
both at least in rhetoric trying to
fight to win over the working class of
America so that being said look my
politics on the
are very much of the view that we need
to put the working class not just here
but around the world at the center of
our politics and really fight for their
interests not just try to appeal to
racial anxiety in a cheap way that I
think we've seen by the right in this
country certainly if Donald Trump Steve
ban and etc and that we see around the
world as well now the great thing about
soldering for those who have watched the
show you know this he comes at these
things from from a very genuine
perspective of he really believes that
immigration restriction ISM is going to
be better for working-class people here
he really believes in this nationalist
view that says basically we have to take
care of our people first that's primary
and then after we do that we can look
around the world where as I see much
more of an importance between solidarity
of working-class people's around the
globe so that's kind of the essential
difference between the two of us he as
you know is critical of Donald Trump on
many things critical of the ban and view
on many things but he comes at this from
a sort of genuine and non racist place
which you know can be unusual in certain
circles in the right yeah well I mean I
think so one interesting academic who
studies populism is Federico Finkelstein
at the new school in New York City and
he's talked a lot about how in a sense
neoliberal globalization and the
anxieties it produces either consciously
or subconsciously are responsible for a
lot of the rise in both left and right
wing populism in the United States and
around the world the difference is that
on the right a lot of it becomes
cultural anxiety the anxiety about
losing what some considered to be a
privileged status in society and then on
that leads to a sort of politics more
based out of fear in right-wing populism
which is where you get the nationalist
stuff and you get the yeah populism for
the people that we define to be inside
of our circle not so much for the people
outside of it which is in a sense what
you're you're kind of alluding to as
well unbeliev you also say if I can just
echo that yeah you also see a pairing
that you know use of like white racial
anxiety with a fundamentally corporatist
view so that's what I've seen in the
Trump administration they throw these
bones of sort of identity politics
racial anxiety politics to the white
working-class base
meanwhile it's the same Paul Ryan
corporatist agenda of making sure Amazon
can get away with not paying any taxes
that we've seen for decades so there's a
lack of genuine care and concern for the
working-class I mean the latest Trump
budget has him cutting entitlements
right that's what he's advocating for
something that he explicitly said he
would not do in his campaign and that is
not just here that's something that
commonly unfolds around the globe as
well yeah I mean we've seen that those
right-wing populist ideas I mean
certainly Trump Nigel Farage in the UK
Modi of India you could make an argument
there's elements of that even even IDO
on in Turkey it feels to me a populism
of us together against them right versus
what you talked about in terms of
inclusion of more the concept of us
against them is flawed it's about all of
us together and that's kind of how I
would summarize it at the top level in a
sense yeah I think that's right and look
I think neoliberalism is kind of the
mirror image of that you have a selling
out of the you know diverse
working-class base of the party in on
economic issues and the way they keep
them in the tent is just basically being
like well at least we're not racist like
the GOP codes are pretty you know in
that that's effective because yeah you
don't want to vote for a party that has
contempt for you so of course you stay
in the tent but actually trying to
deliver a economic populist message that
would cut across all racial and gender
lines and appeal to the broad
working-class in America Democratic
Party hasn't been doing that for a long
time and so in the book what we try to
do and David you get this because we
watch like CNN and MSNBC and how they
get literally everything wrong like you
know you would have thought there would
have been some soul-searching or like
what are we not understanding about the
American electorate at this point but no
they haven't done any of that and so if
they had been correct right now Kamala
and baito would be battling it out for
the nomination right Bernie Sanders was
supposed to be yesterday they still
don't believe that he could be the
nominee when obviously he he is the
farmer he has the clear shot at becoming
the Democratic nominee so what our
thesis is which I suspect you'll agree
with is is you can't understand politics
today and understand the rise of Trump
and understand the rise of Bernie and
AOC and and the new left in the country
if you don't grapple with the core rot
in America why is it that the top-line
numbers the GDP and the stock market is
so good and yet you have people
literally killing themselves at record
and historic rates like what went wrong
there if you don't understand that anger
in the way that art drives our politics
you're gonna be completely confused by
everything that you see unfolding in our
politics right now so let's talk a
little bit about the Bernie Trump thing
so there there are some who say and this
is not my view but I want to explore it
with you that the sort of crossover
appeal from a Bernie supporter to Trump
or vice versa is significant let's call
it signal zero to some degree and one of
the the facts that some try to cite is
look at how many Bernie primary voters
in 2016 ultimately voted for Trump now I
don't think that's a very good argument
because not that many did I mean if you
look it was about 1 in 10 Bernie primary
voters voted Trump and if you look at
2008 you had a higher share of Hillary
primary voters who voted McCain solely I
don't believe that the mathematical
argument is a good one but right the
philosophical argument about even though
it seems as though Bernie and Trump are
so different that there is something of
a crossover appeal how valid do you
think that assessment is look it's I
always get nervous about this because
they are very different politicians with
very different views approaches you know
values all of those things where I see
most of the perilous and look we can
point to the obvious policy things right
on trade there
lot of similarities on at least some of
the stances Donald Trump claimed to hold
in that race against Hillary Clinton
even on health care I mean he basically
supported a single-payer system in that
race he backed lifting the minimum wage
she said he would never cut entitlements
like there were some parallels there
although I think those were more
rhetorical than you know actually the
way that he's governed well that's the
thing just to explore that a tiny bit
more not to interrupt but here Trump was
so obviously pandering in line when he
said those things should we even
consider them agreements when they were
so transparently untrue I don't think
but you know on trade I think there are
actually a lot of that's the one area
where he has been more or less you know
consistent with the way that he ran and
there are parallels there but I don't
even think that that's really the most
important thing I think the more
important parallel is the
anti-establishment dynamic and look
there are lots of things to criticize
Donald Trump about lord knows and I've
I've criticized him on plenty of them
but there's also been you know attempts
to just completely smear everyone in
voted for him as racist or sexist etc
and dismissed the entire movement and
condemned every you know person who
would ever support him in that way that
we see basically playing out right now
with the whole Bernie bro narrative that
oh you have to be toxic or problematic
to support Bernie Sanders I do think
that the media look I you know hate to
stick up for him but I do think the
media has been unfair in the fact that
every single story on CNN and MSNBC has
to have a Trump is bad angle which is
just you know it becomes caricature
right not every last thing that the man
does is bad a lot of it is but not
everything is and also not every story
is about him so like I covered the the
teachers movement extensively which was
incredibly significant largest sort of
labor uprising that we've had certainly
in my lifetime and I got so little play
on these networks that claim to care
about these working-class values because
they didn't have it
a tidy Trump angle so there's also just
this you know incredible inability to
understand why anyone would genuinely
support him for non racist or sexist or
nefarious reasons that I see paralleled
with Bernie Sanders so for example you
have Chuck Todd just recently equating
Sanders supporters to brown shirts like
the supporters of the guy who could be
the first Jewish president who lost
relatives in the Holocaust are compared
to brown shirts something that the ADL
condemned him for it's hard not to see a
similar sort of smearing of Trump
supporters as well no doubt about it and
I think we're where the rubber sort of
ultimately meets the road on the the
sort of non Trump stories is that it's
not only that there's not a tidy Trump
angle sometimes but in general stories
that don't have like a coherent
beginning middle and end where you said
this is this is the start and the story
has now ended
those stories get less coverage and
that's why the judges issue which I've
been talking about which is of course I
mean these are people that are being
selected by Trump but whoever is the
Republican president would be selecting
similar judges are coming by and being
approved by the Senate confirmed by the
Senate and there's barely any coverage
of it it's not really it from story but
it's a story that will affect the
country for decades and it's a gem I
mean
exactly right my children and their
children will be dealing with the
fallout of that development there's also
a reluctance to cover stories in which
Democrats are also complicit right so
you know war-making right the fact that
they basically the Democratic
establishment basically gave him a blank
check just as they have for every
president since 9/11 to do whatever he
wants overseas that doesn't get nearly
as much energy even though in my view is
much more dangerous American public into
world stability then even you know what
he did in Ukraine which wasn't okay
wasn't acceptable but there's so much
more heat and obsession around that then
the fact that he you know almost
stumbled us into war with Iran which
would have massive implications for
decades to come
the
things are not covered on an equal basis
at all because there's so much
Democratic complicity in the latter
we've been speaking with crystal ball
journalist pundit co-host of the hills
rising and also co-author of the book
the populist guide to 2020 a new right
and new left are rising crystal really
appreciate your time
great great being with you David thank
you so much